cancer is as old as human life itself
the first known written reference to
cancer appears in a 15-foot papyrus
prepared by an Egyptian physician 4,000
years ago he numbered all the diseases
and their treatments known to the
ancient world case number 45 refers to
swellings of the breasts large spreading
and hard under the section titled
treatment it reads simply there is none
the main impetus for for making the book
and the documentary was was to sort of
give us a road map of where we are and
where we're going with cancer research
I'd like to describe the documentary as
a kind of report card on cancer and it's
it's not just documentary I think of it
as news in some ways you know in our
long and complex struggle against this
family of diseases called cancer we've
really not had a report card we haven't
had a time in which we've sort of taken
a step back and said let's create a way
to think about what's been achieved what
but what the challenges are what the
next steps are in a very global sense
all the way from the basic science to
the delivery of extremely complex new
innovative cancer care to patients we
have an incredible series of resources
here at Columbia that are really
unmatched around the world on one hand
we have a community hospital where
patients really come off the large
community that we have around the campus
but also we have a really a
state-of-the-art academic medical center
where the capacity to collaborate with
leaders in the field of lymphoma in the
field of leukemia in the biology of
multiple diseases multiple forms of
cancer is really unmatched there's not
one kind of cancer but there are many
kinds of cancers and that even within
let's say a pay particular specimen of
of you let's say just take breast cancer
or even take her2 positive breast cancer
one woman's breast cancer in the genetic
sense is different from another woman's
breast cancer even though they might
share some common features so one of the
large projects that's going on right now
is a project of determining to what
extent do different cancers share common
features and to what extent are they
really different cancer is not a disease
which is a just a cell in isolation but
in fact has a physiological context and
to understand cancer you need to
understand its physiological context
which means collaborating with people
who don't necessarily work on cancer and
to treat cancer you need similarly a
collaborative context in which you are
asking for help from people in kidney
diseases from people who from doctors
who take care of bone diseases from
doctors who are in the neurological
center so I think this is this kind of
collaboration is very unique and it
really plays to the strengths of the
department's you can imagine an end to
cancer and the answer is probably no but
a thoughtful no I think will prevent
some cancers we will treat some cancers
we will cure some other cancers and some
will remain challenges and the diversity
of our approach to the diversity of
cancer will reflect the complex biology
of this disease